now we do overreact on Monday with the
NFL but I wanted to have Kirk Herbstreit
on from the mothership because do we
overreact to college football do we
overreact to anything that we saw over
the weekend and we bring in Kirk
Herbstreit by the way College GameDay
will be in Louisville second consecutive
year that'll be coming up this weekend
ABC Saturday Night Football
it'll be Clemson versus Louisville at
8:00 Eastern and Kirk Herbstreit joins
us herby thanks for joining us the
overreaction in college football today
is what that Oklahoma is gonna win the
national championship you know they went
into Columbus and and second half just
completely dominated Ohio State so yeah
you're gonna have you're gonna have that
reaction but they I tell you what they
look healthy if you look at the
landscape around the country right now
you can make an argument they look as
good as anybody in the country a couple
weeks but yeah I think College NFL
football anything you see those teams
you've been waiting so long and you have
a perception of what you think what's
gonna happen and when that does not
happen what for better or worse people
are just gonna obviously go off the deep
end on what they think might might be
coming up down the road what do you
think the reaction is in Ohio in
Columbus today you lived in Ohio and you
know how you know sometimes the economy
is affected especially in central Ohio
by how high so it is it is get rid of
actually that would might be the better
overreaction is get rid of JT Barrett
Ohio State I'm just saying what some of
the if you're doing a local radio show
in Columbus today it's going to be get
rid of JT Barrett fire the offensive
coordinator our defense is terrible you
know it'll be that kind of reaction I
would think people overreacting to Baker
Mayfield I think they're under reacting
to how he played I think they're
overreacting to the flag incident after
the game your thoughts is yeah you were
watching yeah I think that's fair I
think I think the way he played it was a
great reminder that people forget this
kid first two years as a starter and
Norman ended up in New York City as a
Heisman finalist and right now if he
stays healthy there's no reason to
believe he is
headed back in that direction again the
kids a just one of the more competitive
players I've watched and played that
position and he played with a with a
chip on his shoulder against Saturday
night so I'm with you the way he played
was incredible what happened after the
game I mean that's just his personality
he felt a little bit tweaked by Ohio
State I guess last year singing their
song at the end of the game and by the
way they do that after every day but he
used that as motivation and so when he
got his chance he did a victory lap with
the flag and then what was surprising is
he took it to the next level when he ran
out to the middle of the field on the
block oh and put the flag down at the 50
that that that was probably a little bit
uncalled for you imagine if you would
have done that if you beat Michigan and
you decided to plant the flag there at
the big house yeah I don't you know what
I think I was trying to think back I
mean tio when he scored a touchdown in
the middle of a game running out to the
star and in doing that you know was you
know above and beyond but I can't really
think of a guy doing anything like that
there was something with Michigan and
Michigan State a few years ago where a
Michigan player in East Lansing did
something in a pregame but I you know
that that was if you know Baker personal
personally which I do he's just one of
you guys I keep saying he's a young
Brett Favre like I'm talking Southern
Miss early early Green Bay Packer Brett
Farr where he just plays he plays the
game like if you beat him in ping-pong
he's you're not ending you're playing
again and if you beat him in checkers
like and then if he beats you he's gonna
stand up and and let you know about it
like he just it's just his way I don't
think he meant it to come across in a
way that was belittling or just been
completely disrespectful I think he was
it was more playful for him but
obviously when you do with you what he
did it's it's definitely not going to
come across that way to Ohio State fans
anyway he's Kirk Herbstreit game day
will be at Louisville it's Clemson
against Louisville coming up Saturday
night I find the Lamar Jackson
opinions to be interesting that you have
this kid who had an incredible year you
win the Heisman and it's like we want to
move on from Lamar Jackson because he
doesn't fit the NFL prototype let's move
on we're gonna squeeze in rows in there
Darnell's ready Baker Mayfield may
become Lamar Jackson is actually better
I think this year than last year and I
don't know if people are going to give
him enough credit for what he's gonna do
this year well you know on the preseason
when you do all these shows in August
everybody wants to talk and forecast
who's gonna win this who's gonna win
that and what about the Heisman I've
never seen a guy win the Heisman as a
sophomore and come back and nobody
really want to talk about it and I think
it had everything to do with the way
they're seasoned and and I don't think
it's well how does he project to the NFL
if you remember they they were on the
kind of that at five six five late in
the year in November and everybody
thought this team is still a factor in
the playoff and then they got
embarrassed on a Thursday night by
Houston I think he was fact 10 or 11
times they lost to Kentucky they went to
their bowl game and got sacked eight or
nine times against LSU so they just
faded and and it was interesting he
still won the Heisman despite those
losses and I think coming into this year
those three games I think we're on
people's minds well he didn't play well
the team didn't protect them and I think
people just forgot about him but as
we've seen in these first two weeks he
is a human highlight every time his
hands are on the football you hold your
breath if there's an electrifying player
in the country by far it's him so for
him to come in this week and go up
against arguably their one of the best
defenses if not the top defense in the
country the Clemson Tigers it'll be
it'll be great defending national champs
against defending Heisman Trophy winner
but you're right he's he's not quite yet
getting probably the hype that he
deserves and if he wins this weekend
that that will change in a hurry when I
watch Sam darn 'old if I was trying to
explain what he does so well the
brilliance of Sam darn 'old I don't I
don't know if I could put it into words
I it's almost like you have to
watch what he does and and you played
the position there are certain guys who
played the position and have just
they're wired differently and it feels
like Donald is wired differently what do
you see with Darnell that stands out so
much thing that stands out to me is he's
a flat liner if you watch him that
there's never a moment it's too big for
him and I think if you talk to Bill
Polian of the world and anybody who
evaluates quarterbacks who are in in
college and tries to project them how
they'll be able to fit into the NFL I
think sometimes we get caught up in the
system that they run or how fast they
are or how big an arm they have or that
there may be there there's six for 235
pounds or whatever it is we get caught
up and sometimes that aspect of it but
at the end of the day there's two things
that matter is your decision-making and
your accuracy so those are the tooth
when the dust settles those are the two
things in any quarterback that you're
evaluating and Sam darn 'old is able to
in my opinion do that as well as any
quarterback in the college game and then
you throw in what I think is also
important mental toughness like an
ability to face that third and eight
when you're going to get blitzed or your
team's down by four with three minutes
to go and you get the ball in your hands
either have that personality to be able
to handle that or you don't
and and Sam Donald from the time he took
over last year for max Brown the
pressure being that USC quarterback he
just kind of taken it in kind of a
ho-hum attitude playing Stanford this
past week he doesn't really play with a
chip on his shoulder he doesn't really
play a lot of emotion he just is able to
go out and and execute that offense and
I think clay Helton the head coach in
tmartn their offense coordinator they've
kind of found what works for him where
his strengths are and he's a actually a
very athletic kid high school basketball
player or the best players in his area
and so the reason I say that because if
you watch and you do so much of the NFL
stuff when you watched a great collar or
a great NFL quarterbacks they're not
necessarily running as much but they had
that pocket awareness they're athletic
enough to move around in the pocket
avoid a little bit of a pass rush move
there
slide in the pocket he's that guy and I
think he'll be really really good at the
next level and obviously he's not done
and what he's trying to do this year per
se Herbies safe travels great to talk to
you tell the gang we settle oh I sure
will thanks for having us back we'll
talk to you soon
that's Kirk Herbstreit ESPN College
GameDay analyst the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience